right for me it's a right thing to do
for me as Chief Constable to clearly
State the institutional racism sexism
misogyny and discrimination exist
police Scotland is institutionally
racist and discriminatory publicly
acknowledging these institutional issues
exist in our organization is essential
to our absolutely our absolute
commitment championing equality and
becoming an anti-racist service
it is also critical
the our determination
to lead wider change and support wider
change in society Prejudice and bad
behavior within pushing highlighted by
court and conduct cases various
independent reviews and by listening to
our own officers and staff over recent
years is rightly of great concern
utterly condemned there's no place in
police Scotland where those who reject
our values and standards